[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans l'émission
point de vue nouvelle formule avec deux
invités et deux thèmes d'actualité alors
nos deux invités aujourd'hui c'est
guillaume bernard maître de conférence
de l'institut catholique d'études
supérieures de vente et payés ou bernard
bonjour et ferghana ziari vous êtes
chargé d'études à l'iref l'institut de
recherches économiques et fiscales et
délégué général de l'académie libre des
sciences humaines bonjour lit de thèmes
dont on va parler aujourd'hui et sur
lesquels vous pouvez nous poser des
questions sur twitter sur le site et y
répondre à notre sondage notre sondage
entre guillemets premier thème c'est
hidjab faut-il l'accepter à l'assemblée
nationale et le deuxième thème
patrimoine
l'état doit-il en faire plus alors le
premier thème c'est lié à une polémique
vous avez j'imagine tous entendu parler
quand les députés les républicains et
une députée de la république en marche
ont quitté la salle de la commission d'
enquête sur les effets du co vide sur
les enfants et la jeunesse
ils protestaient contre la présence
d'une femme voilée en l'occurrence la
vice-présidente du syndicat étudiant de
l'unef
mariam pougetoux je vous propose
d'écouter ou de réécouter les changes
qui a eu lieu à l'assemblée nationale
pierre henri dumont anne-christine donc
c'était aussi pour un rappel au
règlement
vous avez la parole mais très peu de
temps on sait rien donc merci madame la
préside
rappelle madame la présidente nous on
constate avec regret qu un syndicat
étudiant auditionnés a fait choix
d'enfreindre le principe même de laïcité
auquel doit s'astreindre notre assemblée
le sujet des conséquences de la crise
sanitaire sur l'avenir de la jeunesse de
notre pays est assez grave pour que la
représentation nationale n'ait pas à
subir dans ce temple de la démocratie
les démonstrations communautariste de
certains le syndicat étudiant autrefois
majoritaire faire un choix délibéré que
nous n'acceptons pas attachés aux
valeurs de notre république
conscient du symbole terry pour notre
assemblée cette attaque préméditée
nous pouvons cautionner cette image de
la représentation nationale restée
silencieuse et masqué face à cet acte
politique communautariste délibéré les
députés les républicains décident donc
madame la présidente madame le
rapporteur de quitter cette audition
merci alors vous allez me faire le
plaisir d'entendre ma réponse comme ça
on remettra peut-être aussi les les
règles aucune règle n'interdit le port
de signes religieux dans le cadre de nos
travaux pour les personnes auditionnées
non mais laissez moi finir je vous ai
écouté jusqu'au bout le port de signes
religieux par ailleurs accepté pour les
personnes assistent en séance publique
dans l'hémicycle de l'assemblée
nationale
la seule règle prévue par notre
instruction générale du bureau
s'applique aux députés dans l'hémicycle
l'article 9 prévoit que ces derniers ne
peuvent porter des signes religieux
ostensibles en uniforme des logos des
messages commerciaux des slogans de
nature politique
je rappelle enfin que la règle de
neutralité du service public
s'appliquent aux agents publics dans
l'exercice de leurs fonctions cette
règle ne trouvant aucune moins
s'impliquer dans le cadre d'une audition
menée à l'assemblée nationale je laisse
le choix de partir si vous le souhaitez
mais c'est un mauvais procès la
présidente vous avez le droit de ne pas
voir le symbole qu'il ya derrière nous
nous le voyons c'est pour ça que je
parte en effet je ne peux accepter qu'au
sein de l'assemblée nationale le coeur
battant de la démocratie ou d'eau règne
les valeurs fondatrices de la république
dont la laïcité nous acceptions qu'une
personne se présente en diable devant
une commission d' enquête
j'entends ce que dit le règlement de
l'assemblée nationale
je pense qu'il ya une nuance
personnellement entre une personne qui
est présente dans le public et une
personnes qui participent à nos travaux
à mon sens c'est assez différent
le port du hidjab dans le cadre de nos
travaux est incompatible à la fois avec
les belles les valeurs qui sont les
miennes concernant les relations entre
les hommes et les femmes et avec l'idée
que je me fais de notre institution de
la laïcité et des valeurs républicaines
dont elle doit continuer à être le
temple et le coeur battant je vous
remercie
nous ne laisserons pas ce faux débat
autour du voile rentrer dans cette
commission qu'elle est censée travailler
sur l'avenir et sur le présent de la
jeunesse dans une situation très
compliquée donc on vous remercie quitté
la salle et on va poursuivre no no no no
no entretien sans vous ce sera beaucoup
plus constructif je rappelle qu'aucune
règle n'interdit le port de signes
religieux dans le cadre de nos travaux
pour les personnes auditionnées
merci voilà le les gens j'étais un peu
long mais je crois que c'était bien
d'entendre toutes les parties prenantes
alors ferghana ziari et ce cas votre
avis les députés ont eu raison de
quitter la salle de la commission âgées
ces arguments c'est à dire quitte à
dénoncer un symbole rétrograde qui est
l'étendard d'une religion ou d'une
idéologie autoritaire je pense qu'il
faut le faire avec de bons arguments
je ne suis pas convaincu ici que la
laïcité soit le bon argument parce que
la laïcité c'est un principe
constitutionnel administratif
on l'a entendu c'est un principe qui
concerne surtout donc l'état et donc les
rapports que l'état les agents entretien
avec avec les religions les églises
n'est ce pas et donc ce principe de
laïcité il n'anime pas la société civile
d'être neutre donc on soit effectivement
à rillieux avec un costume ou y
un accoutrement religieux pour une
personne qui vient de la société civile
comme c'est le cas de cette donc
militante à l'unef n'est pas une entrave
à la laïcité ceci dit cet accoutrement
pose une autre question mais c'est une
question qui est on va dire anne
expliqué tout aussi importante c'est
celle en réalité du symbole et de
l'idéologie véhiculée par cet
accoutrement est donc le problème en
effet du job c'est pas le temps la
laïcité c'est le problème que c'est
c'est le de l'étendard d'une idéologie
autoritaire d'une idéologie rétrograde
d'une idéologie totalitaire liberticide
et donc c'est au nom des valeurs de
liberté et de pluralisme des idées dit
et qu'il faut en effet refuser la
banalisation de ce symbole et en ce sens
je pense que les députés qui se sont
levés ont bien fait de le faire puisque
ça ça après tout ça a bien marché on en
parle aujourd'hui et c'est important de
rappeler en effet que c'est
ses vêtements ne sont pas anodins mais
attention à ne pas mêler la laïcité
parce qu'on risque finalement de groupe
et l'enjeu culturel et non pas seulement
juridique et constitutionnel du combat
contre l'islam radical
guillaume bernard bossi alors vous êtes
d'accord avec le distinguo que fait
ferghana ziari sur laïcité par rapport
et surtout est-ce que
vous aussi vous auriez quitter la salle
vous comprenez les députés qui ont
quitté la salle oui c'est plus la
question de savoir si je les comprends
pas parce qu'il ya peu de chances que je
disais déjà conséquent effectivement je
ne suis pas dans la situation d'avoir eu
à faire le choix je suis a priori plutôt
hostiles à la police des vêtements il me
semble que le problème du port du voile
islamique du hidjab du niqab accélère du
burkini c'est un problème et ça vient
d'être dit un problème culturel
c'est là qu'en fait c'est le problème
d'une immigration trop importante d'une
immigration non assimilés et d'une
immigration conquérante c'est ça le
problème
et quand on entend les parlementaires
parler du temple de la démocratie ou de
la laïcité je crois qu'effectivement il
se trompe totalement d'arguments c'est
une question d'identité est pas une
question de droit et il me semble qu'il
ya un point absolument essentiel qui
n'est pas dit mais qui est sous jacent
c'est le fait de dire mais vous vous
rendez bien compte qu'il y avait des
bonnes soeurs qui portait le voile
auparavant il y avait même des moines
qui se tend sur et il y a une différence
fondamentale et c'est là où il ya
l'enjeu politique c'est que le voile des
soeurs catholiques c'est pour signifier
qu'elle se retire du monde politique
qu'elles sont mortes à la société civile
et qu'elle se donne à dieu et qu'elles
vont agir dans un dans un but de charité
là ici le voile est évidemment utilisé
dans un but de conquête et de
renversement de l'ordre culturel et donc
par conséquent ça n'a évidemment rien à
voir donc je suis hostile pour que les
choses soient très claires
je suis aussi à la fête que et bien il y
ait une présence culturelle islamique en
france mais en revanche la police
individuelle des vêtements de chacun des
deux chacune des personnes me paraît
totalement inutile la question a été
posée du règlement de l'assemblée
nationale qui n'interdit pas
effectivement ce port de voile certains
du coup demande notamment une christine
manque de changer le règlement de
l'assemblée pour l'interdire auto au
moins les signes ostensibles vous seriez
d'accord avec une modification du rayon
c'est ça voudrait dire que
ni les députés ni les personnes qui sont
auditionnés par les députés ou par les
parlementaires de manière plus générale
ne pourrait avoir donc d'opinion ou de
sentiments ou de croyances religieuses
et les exprimer je ne sais plus qui l'a
dit si ça a été dit par fergane ou dans
le document mais la laïcité elle
s'applique et je sais si je suis enclin
à critiquer mais en tout cas si on
l'admet pour l'instant la laïcité c'est
la neutralité ou c'est supposé être la
neutralité de l'état
certainement pas le fait de détruire
l'identité culturelle et religieuse d'un
pays alors autre thématique sur ce sujet
on se demande est ce qu'il n'ya pas une
provocation en provocation de la part de
de la personne de l'unef mais peut-être
aussi de la part de la personne qu ils
l'invitent à venir à cette commission
parce qu'au fond ce n'est pas la
première fois que mariam push to vient
avec un voile et portent ce voile de ça
fait depuis deux ans qui à 7,7 pot-limit
je vous propose sur ce sujet d'écouter
ce que disent et ségolène royal ce matin
sur bfm
elle sait qu'elle provoque elle a le
droit de provoquer heureusement que
heureusement qu'on peut être provocateur
dans notre société
la pluie qui a de la liberté mais en
même temps face maya les limites
il ya la règle c'est tout il ya les
droits et devoirs le règlement lui
permet les ben oui mais c'est parce que
le règlement n'a pas pu prévoir ce cas
là donc voilà maintenant il faut prévoir
le règlement que que l'on rentre dans
les commissions d'enquêté la tête
découverte alors attaque préméditée pour
pierre henri dumont qui dénonce un acte
politique communautariste délibéré vous
êtes d'accord fait regardent la série
avec ses ses propos en tout cas je sais
pas s'il faut parler de provocation
peut-être en tout cas ce qui est certain
c'est que ceux qui l'ont invité et
madame pouchou ne pouvait on ne
s'étonnera pas de cette polémique
puisqu'elle a déjà fait l'objet de
remarques similaires il ya quelques
années je crois lorsqu'elle était
interviewé sur bfm
tv donc elle s'attendait nécessairement
à ce genre de réaction qui pour moi sont
tout à fait saine parce que même si en
effet c'est un jeu où les deux camps
s'alimente un petit peu ça entrave la
banalisation d'un symbole qui n'est pas
anodin et moi je suis assez surpris de
voir que la gauche insiste à ce point
pour imposer en tout cas ce genre de de
signes sur la place publique quand bien
même sur le plan juridique je suis
pareil je ne venais pas en vue
d'interdire ce symbole je ne suis pas
pour la police des vêtements non plus je
pense que on doit en effet essayé de de
remédier à ce genre d'enjeu sur à
l'échelle de la société civile donc
question de subsidiarité simplement
c'est quand même étonnant de voir que la
gauche qui a tout ce qui a si souvent
qui s'est si souvent montré autoritaire
pour lutter contre les traditions
qu'elles jugent les plus rétrogrades qui
s'est toujours dit révolutionnaire
progressiste contre les conservatismes
un peu désuet se trouve ici l'apôtre la
plus élevée le plus et les d'un
conservatisme assez autoritaire c'est
assez contradictoire avec l'histoire de
de ce mouvement là et moi je m'interroge
en fait sur ses sauts cette cohérence
contenu de l'histoire intellectuelle de
cette mouvance
vous disiez c'est pas tellement sur la
laïcité qu'il faudrait combattre
peut-être sur l'aspect culturel il
respect des droits des femmes aussi
peut-être sur lequel ça peut être un
argument pour dire voilà ce voile est
souvent imposée est ce que c'est pas au
nom des droits des femmes qu'on peut
soit l'interdire en tout cas de dire ne
pas le mettre dans cet hémicycle
évidemment être un argument mais ce qui
est certain c'est que là on voit la
cassure au sein de la gauche entre ceux
qui d'une certaine manière essaye
d'éviter la communautarisation si tant
est qu'elle n'existe pas déjà
il est de l'autre ceux qui en revanche
joue la communautarisation c'est quand
même la représentante du syndicat unef
qui est quand même une organisation
c'est non c'est évident et ça reviendra
ça arrive il est exactement ça et donc
évidemment énormément
bouger et donc on voit bien qu'il y à là
toute une partie de la gauche qui met
cette jeune femme avec ce signe qu'ils
utilisent même comme porte parole donc
comme porte étendard et qui à l'évidence
veut favoriser et bien le délitement de
la société au bénéfice je dirais d'une
de l'espérance qu'il y aurait un
prolétariat de substitution dans les
immigrés qui paie les flatter en leur
permettant de ne pas s'assimiler mais de
revendiquer leurs origines je vous fait
voir le tweed de clémentine autain si
vous l'avez pas déjà vu qui va dans le
sens de ce que vous dites sur un an ces
deux gauche puisque elle fait un
rapprochement entre la tenue de la jeune
femme de l'unef
et voilà ce moine bouddhiste ce prêtre
catholique et ce rabbin qui reviennent
avec leur leur signe elle fait elle y
met une sorte de parallèle oui alors
c'est la différente isme culturel
c'était à qu'en france il n'y aurait
aucune identité n'y aurait aucun lien
substrat est donc tout ce vaudrait et
tous devraient être acceptable c'est la
vieille théorie du contrat social où
tout se vaut et cyniquement la rencontre
de la volonté non je suis désolé il y a
une identité en france et le problème du
niqab du hidjab du burkina etc
c'est pas un problème de laïcité c'est
un problème d'identité je ne dirais pas
ça une question d'identité c'est une
question quand il faut d'idéologie c'est
à dire que si ce symbole et étrangers
mais inoffensif à la rigueur on pourrait
l'accepter c'est pas le caractère
étranger en ici du vêtement qui pose
problème
tout à l'heure vous avez lier ces
problématiques liées à l'immigration
mais enfin je sais pas combien
d'immigrés ont subi mais tous ne porte
pas le voile et tous ne sont pas
musulmans donc je vois pas ici le lien
en logique entre l'idée d'être un
immigré d'être forcément musulmans ce
sont deux choses qui sont complètement
différente maintenant en effet il y a
aujourd'hui une espèce de d'égalitarisme
un peu le culturel qui me semble-t-il
est un peu mal placé parce qu'on sait
très bien que toutes les religions ne se
valent pas toutes les religions ne sont
pas également soluble dans les normes
civilisationnel occidental qui
s'articule autour de la liberté de
l'égalité et du pluralisme on sait que
l'islam n'a pas l'âme le même rapport à
la politique à la liberté que
le catholicisme ou autres donc on fait
ici semblant de croire que tout est
pareil alors que de la même manière
qu'au sein même du spectre politique
toutes les idéologies politiques ne se
valent pas et bien dans la sphère
religieuse toutes les religions ne se
valent pas mais ce n'était pas une
question d'origine question de l'essence
même de l'idéologie que l'on traite ici
or le problème c'est que la gauche
aujourd'hui très complexé de voir qu'il
existe une religion en particulier qui
est par essence beaucoup plus
autoritaire que les autres alors ça
provoque beaucoup de réactions parmi les
internautes je vous en cite une selle de
brobo nino qui nous dit nous sommes le
seul pays au monde où il existe encore
ce type de débat absurde sur le voile le
reste du monde nous rionnais c'est je
suis pas sûr je pense que dans beaucoup
de pays
justement on se pose ces questions là et
et notamment dans les pays anglo saxons
c'est à dire qu'on fait ici son nom de
croire que la critique de l'islam serait
un monopole occidental vous même que
dans les pays du maghreb on à ces débats
là on a une espèce de 2,2 de jeunesse
aussi qui aspirent à des sociétés plus
sécularisée on le voit en iran avec les
femmes la jeunesse qui manifeste contre
le régime des mollahs qui enlèvent leur
voile donc mon fin ici de ne pas voir
que la lutte contre un totalitarisme
ici donc le totalitarisme islamique est
un combat universel qui ne concerne pas
seulement l'occident et le monde
occidental
toutes les sociétés qui veulent
effectivement être plus libres tout
simplement les gens muto qui dit plonge
le taux était en mission elle savait
qu'elle aurait des soutiens parmi les
élus effectivement on a l'impression que
c'était quand même assez bien préparés
oui sa réponse était très clair et très
net et est très effectivement très
argumenté donc on peut penser qu'elle
qu'ils y réponse est oui alors il y
avait la question il jappe faut-il
accepter à l'assemblée nationale et on
voit la réponse assez clair je crois de
nos internautes qui sont non aller à
dire à 68%
j'imagine que de toute façon on va
reparler de ce sujet dans l'est dans les
jours qui viennent c'est de sonder sujet
inépuisable même si voilà il ya
peut-être qu'en france où beaucoup en
fait en france on y est sensible mais
alors le deuxième thème de notre
émission peut-être moins politique
quoique quoique patrimoine l'état
doit-il en faire plus
donc vous le savez ce week-end ce sont
les fameuses journées européennes du
patrimoine est aujourd'hui emmanuel
macron était à condom dans le gers avec
la ministre de la culture bachelot mais
également stéphane bern qui est le
promoteur du fameux loto du patrimoine
qui permet de rénover des bâtiments
alors finalement faute d'argent l'état
se tourne vers les citoyens volontaires
cette fois ci peuvent sous forme
d'impôts pour sauvegarder son patrimoine
alors vous dites quoi
guillaume bernard c'est navrant ou au
contraire bon bah finalement c'est ça
peut être une bonne chose si on ça
arrive à sauver des notre patrimoine
non mais toute solution qui essayent je
dirais de colmater les brèches pourquoi
pas et je trouve que stéphane bern est
généralement assez sympathique et et qui
témoigne publiquement je dirais dandan
amour pour le patrimoine français et
l'histoire française qui est assez assez
intéressante et et comme on dirait
agréable le problème si vous voulez
c'est que moi je n'ai pas de position
définie a priori sur quel doit être le
rôle de l'état ou des collectivités
locales parce qu'il ya aussi les
collectivités locales
d'ailleurs je ne dis pas qu'il ne doit
pas intervenir ou qu'ils devraient de
toute façon intervenir
le mot a été prononcé tout à l'heure
mais généralement c'est plutôt moment
même couronne penser qu'il le revendique
c'est le terme de subsidiarité c'est à
dire qu'en fonction des circonstances
la puissance publique doit ou non se
substituer aux personnes privées qui je
dirais non
sont défaillantes mais le problème c'est
que si les personnes privées sont
défaillantes et c'est là où je
rejoindrai fergane vraisemblablement
c'est que si elles sont défaillantes
pour entretenir le patrimoine c'est
peut-être parce que la spoliation de
l'état est tel que ils n'en n'ont plus
les moyens
c'est que s'ils imposent sur l'impôt sur
la fortune a été supprimé mais pas pour
l'immobilier et on sait très bien que
effectivement des familles qui veulent
transmettre un patrimoine qui veulent
entretenir un patrimoine sont
aujourd'hui devant des grandes
difficultés donc je crois que la
première des choses que doit faire l'êta
avant d'intervenir
c'est déjà de laisser les personnes
privées pouvoir intervenir qu'ensuite la
possibilité exactement financièrement
fiscalement etc ensuite effectivement si
jamais les personnes privées sont
défaillantes je crois que pour sauver
des joyaux du patrimoine il est
nécessaire que la collectivité et donc
l'impôt soit susceptible d'intervenir
j'imagine que le libéral fergane gary
gray d'accord laissons les personnes
privées donnons les moyens aux personnes
privées d'intervenir et par l'état oui
la question vous posez là c'est l'état
peut-il en faire plus alors oui
théoriquement il le peut la question qui
se pose en effet s'il n'y a pas d une
manière plus paisible moins coercitives
touati louis ballard dans ce cas là la
question est beaucoup plus et beaucoup
plus clair oui je pense que nous
devrions images et des politiques
culturelles plus respectueux de la
subsidiarité ça existe déjà c'est à dire
que c'est pas seulement théorique le
mécénat aujourd'hui prend de plus en
plus d'ampleur les établissements
culturels y compris gouvernementaux ont
de plus en plus ce recours à des mécènes
pour rénover des bâtiments le panthéon
je crois a été rénové par du
crowdfunding donc ça ce fait les acteurs
culturels y compris publiques sont déjà
sur ce sur ce terrain là
pour ce qui est du lot du patrimoine
c'est un bon exemple comment une espèce
de dynamique un peu commercial peut
aussi servir à la rénovation du
patrimoine donc la philanthropie
moi je pense que s'il elle pouvait
prendre le plus de place possible quitte
à se substituer complètement la
puissance publique et bien ça ne serait
ce serait toujours plus respectueux du
consentement des populations donc tant
mieux
vraiment je m'interroge aussi sur
l'opportunité par exemple
de confier les bâtiments aux parties
prenantes qui ont le plus intérêt à la
conservation par exemple nous demandait
ce que les églises ne devraient pas être
rendus à l'église catholique pourquoi
les garder entre les girons dans le
giron des des communes ou de la
puissance publique est ce qu'il n'ya pas
aussi une manière d'intéresser davantage
les gens à la conservation du patrimoine
précisément patrimonia lisant les choses
qui aujourd'hui sont entre les mains de
la fonction publique et qui n'a pas les
mêmes d'incitation pour les conserver
guillaume bernard qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cette proposition a de rendre
les églises à les lieux de culte à
l'église catholique
ce serait évidemment quelque chose
d'intéressant
voyez comme quoi un sujet qui pourrait
ne pas être polémique peut effectivement
le devenir parce qu'on sait bien qu
évidemment après la spoliation des biens
des congrégations et que la loi de 1901
il ya eu la spoliation de la loi de 1905
qui elle-même s'appuie sur les biens
nationaux
bon je crois qu'on n'a pas le temps
évidemment que c'est pas le sujet de
développer ici mais ce sera un bon sujet
sur lequel on pourrait on pourrait
évidemment débattre je crois sincèrement
que le fond du problème c'est de savoir
est-ce que d'abord on est motivés est ce
que il y a un goût de la population qui
a conservé je dirais un attachement pour
son passé et et ou pas et je sais
qu'aujourd'hui malgré les immenses
difficultés qu'il peut y avoir
financières pour maintenir du patrimoine
il y a quand même des initiatives
privées pour le faire je pense à la
chapelle-basse-mer l'association mémoire
du futur qui a remonté de toutes pièces
une chapelle du 11e siècle qui a
construit un prieuré une salle et c'est
pour pouvoir faire un mémorial de la
vendée et ça ils l'ont fait sans un sou
d'argent public et malgré la pression
fiscale qui fait que malgré tout chacun
d'entre nous eh bien nous sommes
évidemment limité donc vraiment je crois
que la logique de l'intervention de la
puissance publique collectivités
territoriales ou état ça doit être la
subsidiarité
mais il est certain qu'il y aurait des
bâtiments je le sais très bien en vendée
qu'il y aurait des bâtiments qui aurait
disparu
si le conseil général sous la férule de
philippe de villiers de n'étaient pas
intervenues c'est donc la puissance
publique
elle a son rôle oui et on voit que les
français sont attachés à leur patrimoine
le succès des journées
deux moines les files d'attentes devant
tous les monuments ou quel qu'il soit
montre bien un attachement à d'ailleurs
on voit bien là ça nous fait une
transition et de l'actualité - moins
sympathique mais l'épidémie
coville a entraîné un certain nombre
d'annulations c'est un peu dommage vous
vous trouvez là on en fait peut-être un
peu trop sur l'aspect sanitaire et du
coup on a annulé des visites des lieux
de lieux qui aurait justement pu avoir
lieu je crois que stéphane bern avait
fait cette remarque en effet dans les
médias en déplorant que justement le
coup porté à la sphère culturelle est
mise à mal les financements de pas mal
de d'établissement c'est un autre sujet
c'est ici effectivement le sujet d'un
état qui veut s'arroger le monopole de
la précaution et qui pensent mieux
savoir que nous les risques auxquels
nous devrions ou pas nous nous exposer
donc moi je suis en tant que là encore
dans ce libéral partisan du fait de
laisser des gens arbitrer et faire leurs
propres arbitrages pour pour savoir
quels sont les risques auxquels elles
s'exposaient ou pas mais pour en revenir
sur le mécénat moi je voulais revenir
sur exemple de notre dame de paris table
et je trouve que c'est un très bon
exemple à la fois de nous des vertus et
de la capacité du mécénat a su mobiliser
assez rapidement pour sauver un joyau du
patrimoine français et en même temps
aussi révélateur des blocages et des
mentalités qui font qu'aujourd'hui le
mécénat n'est pas suffisamment développé
puisque je ne sais pas si vous vous
souvenez mais dès lors que les bernard
arnault et les riches ont à nous
suggérer donc leur aide
toutes les critiques un peu envieuse
jalouse anti riches se sont abattues en
disant mais ces gens là doivent payer
leurs impôts et ne doivent absolument
pas participer de leur plein gré à la
rénovation du patrimoine ne s'était pas
donc ces gens là ne sont pas attachés à
la solidarité ils veulent que
l'extorsion
donc ça ça rejoint une espèce de
mentalité d'ancien régime d'auto ville
avait déjà décrite ses idées que la
bureaucratie n'accepte pas les
initiatives la bureaucratie n'accepte
pas la concurrence des initiatives
privées elle veut absolument garder le
monopole et le simple fait de voir la
société civile se constituer sans elle
ça l'a fait ça la fait peur et à côté de
ça il y a chez l'extrême gauche une
espèce de contradiction aussi c'est que
la philanthropie est décrié alors tantôt
le le risque de ne pas assez il n'est
pas assez charitable et donc c'est un
[ __ ] et en temps il donne donne trop
et donc là effectivement il s'arroge
sorlin pouvoir fiscalisés
il s'accroche à un pouvoir qui tiennent
à leur main que en l'occurrence pour
bernard arnault françois pinault il
expliquait que le plafond de
défiscalisation a été atteint donc de
toutes façons les sommes oui il est
concerné pas je suis d'accord et des
regards et quand bien jusqu'au moment où
il parle de l'ancien franc oui et il a
créé une interprétation de l'ancienne
france fondée sur tocqueville autant de
la démocratie en amérique de tocqueville
c'est absolument brillantissime autant
l'ancien régime je crois qu'il commet de
graves erreurs interpellation pour le
reste je suis évidemment enfin je suis
plutôt effectivement d'accord avec vous
et pour parler du coc vide et 2 et je
dirais de la terreur dans laquelle nous
nous vivons
je crois que là on est confronté à
quelque chose qui était un enjeu d'ordre
un peu philosophique mais qui est
important c'est que on nous présente le
principe de précaution comme étant de la
prudence je crois que c'est exactement
l'inversé la prudence c'est d'être
confronté à une situation et au final de
faire un choix
le principe de précaution qu'on nous a
imposée dans la charte de
l'environnement adossée à la
constitution dans le préambule de la
constitution
enfin dans le bloc de constitutionnalité
pardon et bien c'est le fait de dire que
parce qu'il ya un risque comme si la vie
n'était pas entièrement constituée d'une
succession de risque et bien parce qu'il
ya un risque on doit s'abstenir parce
qu'il ya un risque on doit établir une
contrainte et je crois que c'est
exactement l'inversé de la prudence et
c'est là où on s'aperçoit que il y a une
incapacité dans le traitement de cette
affaire de la crise sanitaire à avoir
une certaine modulation en fonction des
lieux en fonction des temps et c'est
sans doute quelque chose de dommages de
dommageable
je pense qu'en revanche en vendée la
plupart des sites seront ouverts vous
pouvez venir les voir très bien alors ce
sujet provoque aussi quand même des
réactions chez nos amis internautes donc
trixie qu'ils disent sur lefigaro.fr
l'état doit faire plus pour le
patrimoine
il ne faut pas le donner au privé la
france a une andy identité une culture
millénaire il faut se remémorer ce qui
fait la france et de nous venons lac qui
va dans le même sens en disant sans
patrimoine on perd peu à peu de son
histoire et anonymes qui nous dit le
patrimoine se renouvelle au fil du temps
il n'y a pas de perte seulement une
évolution
ce qui pose effectivement la question
est ce qu'il faut rénover ce qu'il faut
peut-être faire des choix dans la
rénovation on voit bien vous évoquez le
loto du patrimoine avant stéphane bern a
dû se battre parce que l'administration
lui mettez un peu de bâtons dans les
roues puis finalement la sueur depuis
2018 on voit ses 173 sites qui ont été
aidés c'est pas beaucoup par rapport aux
milliers qui avait demandé une aide
c'est pas beaucoup mais en même temps
rien ne nous empêche de continuer à
faire ce travail et à financer nous
mêmes les rénovations qui ont besoin de
financement donc là encore je pense
qu'il faut apprendre aussi à être plus
autonome et a cessé de demander à l'état
ce conte ce qu'on peut faire par nous
même tout simplement aujourd'hui rien
n'empêche le bienfaiteur de sortir son
chèque thd allait financer les causes
qui est qui lui tient à coeur à
condition est là tout à l'heure
guillaume l'a dit estimant qu'on ait les
moyens de le faire ce qui pose la
question aussi de laisser aux français
la possibilité de disposer du fruit de
leur travail comme il le souhaite alors
l'état la république possède un certain
nombre de châteaux le figaro magazine en
a fait ça sa couverture de ce week-end
sur ses châteaux secret ce qu'on ne peut
pas forcément toujours visiter et
notamment aussi les chasses de de
chambord justement d'ailleurs il ya un
sujet qui fait un peu polémique c'est la
rénovation de l'elysée ces neuf cent
trente mille euros qui ont été dépensés
pour pour rénover notamment et figurait
parce que j'ai quelques poteaux
électriques margueray je veux
sincèrement je n'ai pas d'avis
particulier
disons que le décor est me semble-t-il
est datée surtout de de napoléon iii
c'était un peu lourd j'avais bien le
gris et le blanc marly c'est pas mal
mais c'est vrai que ça peut choquer de
d'avoir transformé des choses ça pose
une vraie question dans la rénovation
c'est est ce qu'il faut refaire à
l'identique mais l'identique de caen on
a eu un problème avec notre dame
évidemment et est-ce qu'il ne faut pas
essayer quand même de 2,2 de mettre de
côté un peu la logique du buzet hier de
mettre sous forme hall un certain nombre
de choses et qu'elle ne vive plus on
sait très bien que des châteaux
médiévaux ont été transformés à l'époque
de la renaissance ça nous a donné des
choses magnifiques penser à blois avec
ses différentes lll louis d'auzielle
l'i3 galley le caisson d'orléans
voilà et je crois que malheureusement
c'est une question là aussi de bon goût
et pas eu de culture et d'identité
beaucoup plus qu'une question de
principe juridique ferghana ziari les
neuf cent trente mille euros pour
rénover un salon alors on parle de 15
mille feuilles d'or ce qui fait 3 190 g
c'est choquant c'est pas choquant est ce
que cet argent on aurait pu l'utiliser
ailleurs
à l'elysée on dit voilà c'était
indispensable y avait des fuites il
fallait faire les travaux il ya un
moment il faut quand même aussi rénover
des bâtiments dans lesquels on travaille
s'il faut rénover le bâtiment pour
colmater les brèches et qui n'est pas de
suite pourquoi pas après au risque de
faire mon comptable un peu austère je
pense qu'aujourd'hui il ya d'autres
priorités on est quand même en récession
on est comme un lot d'une vigne crise
économique sans précédent
et même s'il ne faut pas sacrifier la
culture je précise quand même heure le
sens des priorités
donc c'est aussi aux responsables
politiques de d'être mesurés et d'être
modéré dans le plein d'argent public
alors question vous avez répondu les
internautes l'état doit-il en faire plus
on va voir le le résultat qui s'affiche
c'est assez fait presque plus tranché
que tout à l'heure 84%
oui les toits dans l'état doit faire
plus pour protéger le patrimoine
français
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle en
disant on doit défendre notre patrimoine
c'est plus la question de la défense du
patrimoine à mon avis auquel les
français répondent pense que le fait que
ce soit la puissance publique qu'il le
fasse voilà qu'elle vienne en aide
pourquoi pas et qu'elles sont tous
qu'elles permettent à ceux qui sont
capables et voilà le goulven ans en tant
que personne privée de le faire voilà
merci à tous les deux d'avoir participé
à cette émission
vous nous retrouverez lundi pour une
nouvelle émission d'ici là passez un bon
week-end
au revoir
[Musique]